hey there and welcome to inside the
Oscars I'm Rachel Smith and today we are
taking you into the most exclusive place
in Hollywood the Oscars Green Room on
Oscar night no cameras are allowed but
today we're gonna take you inside for an
exclusive look and where Hollywood's
biggest stars hang out before they take
the stage the green room is a space
right off of the stage for presenters
performers and nominees somewhere where
they can go out of prying eyes there's
no press allowed in there during the
show so it's kind of a nice little haven
away from the hustle and bustle of being
on the red carpet it's to put people in
the right frame of mind to go out and do
the job that they're there to do and I
think the stars love it because once
they've spent all day getting ready for
the show they've done countless
interviews they step into the green room
and relax before they have to go and sit
in their seat for the star of the show
or walk onstage to present an award it's
designed by Architectural Digest
Margaret Russell the editor of AD called
me up and asked if I would like to do
the green room and it felt like just
exactly the right project traditionally
the green room has been a very complete
design ours is more open-ended in that
people will be able to personalize it a
little bit there's an entry there's a
living room there's a bar and then
there's this garden in the back is
actually five at the campus transitional
buffet area the garden in the back
hopefully will be a bit of a surprise
it's not something that's expected and
and the trick is it is with many of
these these rooms is it just feel like
you're in this very protected wonderful
green room so these were just some early
research images about one of the
features that I think is going to be
most unique is what we're calling a
media wall you can see there's three
sizes and we can use it as individual
shots that show people arriving or show
people winning but it can also be used
for show graphics or for instance if
we're looking at one
particular category at home we can show
that as well so it's really going to be
an exciting element you want to create a
place where people are comfortable and
you want to create a place where there's
this sense of community so it's an
interesting design challenge so other
thing that stars themselves being
allowed in the green room there are very
few people that you get to go in there
what's nice is you get to see the stars
let the guard down they can be
themselves they can chill out we want
them to enjoy themselves and have a good
Oscar experience last year we had a
Twitter mirror in the green room and it
was a great opportunity for the nominees
presenters performers that were in the
green room to take pictures of
themselves and send to their fans always
fell down I'm here in the green room at
the Oscars and we're doing it again this
year so check it out on Oscar Sunday to
make sure you don't miss any of the vine
that seems action on Oscar Sunday
check out the Oscar buzz page on Oscar
com